this video is proudly sponsored by
squarespace
working out doesn't have to be
complicated i mean sometimes it is but
if you're a generally healthy person
you're just looking to burn some more
calories maybe lose some weight perhaps
increase your energy levels or prevent
yourself from getting injured maybe even
increase athletic performance then there
are lots of easy things you can do that
will have a profound effect and one of
the easiest and most profound of all is
skipping
just to be really clear i'm not an
expert skipper
skipster in fact if you look at my rope
it's pretty useless i can't do a lot of
tricks but i've occasionally used
skipping as a kind of cardio finisher at
the end of my workouts and as i've come
to appreciate it more this is something
that i'm integrating more into my
workout so i just wanted to share how
i'm doing that and why i'm doing it if
you want to learn the cool moves there's
a channel called jump rope dudes they
teach this sort of thing really good
really interesting makes skipping a lot
more fun so i highly recommend that you
check that out see i've been working on
these skills just recently i've become
interested in them and they're a lot
more tricky than i thought they would be
i actually thought i'd mastered the side
swipe where you swing it to either side
and then i watched the video back and i
realized i actually stopped jumping
every time i did it what i've learned
about skipping form myself is that you
want to keep the elbows in as much as
you can you're rotating primarily at the
wrists and you want to be just leaving
the ground enough to cover the distance
of the rope point is you don't need any
fancy skills if you just want to reap
the benefits of skipping and of course
one of the most obvious benefits of
skipping one of the things that most
people are going to be interested in is
the fact that it's fantastic for burning
calories some estimates suggest that
skipping actually burns more calories
than the equivalent amount of running or
jogging likely i'm not sure whether i
necessarily buy into that but i can
certainly believe the estimates that 10
minutes of skipping will burn somewhere
in the region of 100 to 300 calories
obviously depending on things like your
intensity and your weight and your
height with such calculations it's also
important to consider your basal
metabolic rate the bmr in other words
how many calories would you have burned
if you're just standing still it's not
quite as impressive as it sounds however
it's still pretty not bad point is this
is something you can do anywhere unlike
running which requires you to be outside
you can do skipping on the spot you can
stand in front of your tv and skip if
you worry about smashing things you can
actually skip without a rope you can buy
these special skipping ropes that have
just a ball on the end that you can
swing you can also just swing your hands
and just imagine you're doing it and
that's how i've been incorporating
skipping into my routine i've just been
skipping every now and then throughout
the day just as a way to burn a few
extra calories and of course you get all
the added benefits of this as well such
as increased blood flow you're spiking
your metabolism you're getting more
blood flowing around the body to the
muscles to the brain waking you up and
also supplying all of those tissues with
the nutrients they need to grow and
recover and if it's burning calories
you're interested in and if you want to
get even more benefits in this regard
then you can of course use a weighted
rope which really burns through the
calories you don't have to do much at
all with this to really feel it working
it's going to tone the muscles as well
particularly in the shoulders and the
arms and of course for the grip and for
the wrist this is fantastic training
i've talked a lot recently on this
channel about how important it is to be
more active throughout the day to do
more smaller workouts and to integrate
them throughout your lifestyle so you
feel more awake less lethargic and so
you're burning more calories and
building more muscle constantly skipping
is the perfect tool to do this with if
you guys know me by now i'm not usually
just interested in burning calories what
i really like about skipping is all the
additional benefits you're getting at
the same time and some of these are
really pretty interesting
so one of the most important and
impressive things that skipping can do
for you is to build your bone density
and this is really important especially
as you get older if you want to avoid
fractures and sprains the reason for
this is that skipping provides that
small jolt that small impact that
encourages the bones to break themselves
down and then rebuild themselves
slightly stronger to reabsorb those
minerals it's not skipping specifically
it does this it's jumping jumping is one
of the very best ways to build bone
density but of course a lot of people
are going to struggle to jump if they
have tricky knees or hips or ankles so
skipping can provide a nice gentle way
to get into this if you struggle to jump
the small amount necessary for skipping
then i recommend starting with the 100
up minor i made a video all about this
it has a lot of the same benefits so
i'll put a link to that in description
down below
but assuming you're able to jump i think
it's really important that you do that's
because jumping is in my opinion another
one of these fundamental humor movements
of course it translates to better
athletic performance you'll be better in
sports and in general in life whether
it's jumping up the stairs or anything
else but at the same time it also just
prevents that kind of wear and tear that
deterioration that can happen as you get
older now of course if you find even the
small amount of jumping involved in
skipping to be too impactful if it
creates pain in your knees or your shins
or your ankles then i recommend that
instead you try the 100 up minor i made
a video on this in the past i'll put a
link to that description down below it
offers many of the same benefits and
involves no jumping no impact but it
could slowly build up the kind of
stability you need to get to that point
where you can skip gently
and the other big benefit of skipping is
that it's also great for your brain
because you're actually having to really
focus on the rope as you skip and of
course this goes double if you're also
trying to learn those cool skills so
there is a benefit to doing stuff like
the crisscross and the side swipe
but even when you're just skipping
normally you have to pay attention
to the rhythm as the rope slips
underneath you this is actually really
good for improving your timing as some
studies actually confirm and i've talked
about in another old video timing is
actually very important for your
all-around athletic performance and at
the same time this makes skipping more
enjoyable and more intrinsically
rewarding if you've ever wondered why we
find things like computer games or even
juggling to be
really engaging and easy to stick at
while something like curling weights
isn't it's because the brain is more
involved in the former examples when
you're learning that requires focus and
you get those dopamine hits the brain
loves learning and so what we often
think of as fun is actually just
disguised learning so if you are
learning a new skill such as a new
skipping trick that way you kind of
disguise the fact that you're exercising
it's like playing a team sport you don't
actually feel like you're exercising in
fact it's something you actively want to
do but you get all those benefits so
pick up a rope trying on some new skills
you might just find that you
automatically lose a bit more weight and
if this doesn't work then there's always
beat saber
the next great thing about skipping is
that it builds lots of ankle stiffness
you're enabling yourself to return more
energy to the ground whether you're
sprinting whether you're jumping because
when you look at the way we run when you
look at biomechanics we actually keep
our feet in a somewhat static position
we don't want to dorse effects too much
we want to contract the carve on impact
and then return that energy to the
ground so again this is just an easy and
convenient way that you can improve your
athleticism from the comfort of your own
home and you can do it pretty much
anywhere and one trick if you want to
improve this and this is the variation i
have been practicing is to skip with
just one foot but again you want to
build up to this gradually
this also help to get better absorbing
impact whether you're running or whether
you're landing from a jump because as we
know when you absorb impact you use lots
of muscles to try and dampen that force
such as the anterior tibialis on the
front of the shin now you can train many
of these muscles individually or you can
just practice absorbing a little bit of
impact starting something very nice and
gentle like skipping and then build up
to larger amounts as you're able to
withstand them finally this also teaches
you to land on the balls of your feet
and stay light on your feet and this is
one of the reasons that fighters like
skipping so much as a form of cardio it
teaches them to land on the balls of
their feet keeps them nice and light and
helps to move around quickly so you
found this video useful interesting guys
if you did then please consider leaving
a like and sharing around that would
help me out immensely you've got another
example of an exercise that's really
easy and efficient way to improve your
general fitness and athletic performance
then check out my video on the 100 up or
check out my video on why running once a
week is actually enough to see some
impressive results
if you like this kind of training that
looks not only at your appearance and
your numbers in the gym but also your
all-round health fitness and performance
you might enjoy my ebook and training
program super functional training 2.0
that comes with over two hours of
instructional video as well as an 80
plus page ebook i'll put a link to that
inscription down below as well either
way thank you so much for watching this
one guys and i'll see you next time bye
for
but now you go let's take a moment to
talk about today's sponsor squarespace
so squarespace is an online platform for
developing modern attractive and
professional websites with no coding
necessary
creating the bioneer website ultimately
led to the bioneer youtube channel and
it was honestly one of the very best
decisions i ever made so if you have any
interest in turning your passion into a
career then i highly recommend
considering it and squarespace is the
easy way to go about doing that easy but
feature-rich squarespace really does
have everything you could need so that
includes gated members only content for
easy revenue generation member
management email communication audience
insights then there's the integrated
commenting system with threaded
responses replies and likes there's
powerful blogging tools for sharing
content and categorizing posts and
social media integration to display
posts from your social profiles directly
on your website and for those that
really want to monetize there's also
powerful e-commerce capabilities and
these are made even more powerful with
third-party extensions which provide
inventory management marketing
streamlined bookkeeping sales tax
reconciliation and filing and logistics
for shipping globally go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch bioneer
viewers can get 10 off the purchase of
their first website or domain by going
to squarespace.com forward slash bioneer
today